the latest secret of the island is this
show's starting to suck
on lost these days if you want one
secret about the island you have to sit
through like 27 minutes of
cheating
i'm pregnant
i know last week it said next week on
lost you're pregnant
oh but let's drag this out for 30
minutes
and then at the end find out that the
guy in the vault is evil oh i thought he
was friendly
i thought he was the friendly guy that
we caught in the net and you shot with
an arrow and last week they're like five
big events i'm sorry it's not a big
event just to do exactly what we thought
you were gonna do you know what a big
event would be the whole island blows up
and you know what that would be a relief
because then i could get my life back
thanks a lot
ooh this week echo finds a berry that's
delicious
what a
i wonder if sawyer finds a frog
that was one of the plots
how did we get from the greatest show
ever where they're finding hatches
to episodes where the big plot twists me
but you know what i'm saying they found
a frog
hey there's a frog in the woods
and then it's like a big like another
big secret this season hurley's eating
candy in the in the jungle
that's like it used to be like a big
friggin smoke monster emerged and like
reflected like your life how is it doing
that and then a bear a polar bear and
that horse that kate saw and now it's
like the fat guy's eating candy
and they're treating us like idiots
they're treating us like idiots when
they find the beard she finds the fake
beard that's a twist it's a fake beard
and in case you didn't get it she takes
out the stuff that says like
beard glue
i got it it's a fake beer
i had it there even me she didn't also
need to find dharma initiative beard
glue
i'm like one of its biggest fans this
show keeps punching me in the groin get
to the point where the best part of a
program is the commercial for next
week's program i'm so sorry but it sucks
so bad you know what i keep coming back
with a huge [__] black eye
oh my god it's so good to see you again
lost
this will make it on the website